right that's Brady I'm gonna give you a
mathematical gift I'm gonna give you
many mathematical gifts they'll give you
a very special one today and now to make
it extra special I often ask people when
I do this small my party tricks their
age but that feels a little impersonal
so you want to give me a arbitrary
number between 21 and 65 what would you
what would you what would you like 42 oh
okay right so 42 42 42 40 I guess - all
right there's more I'm just I'm starting
with those digits I'm gonna put a 5 in
over there I'm gonna put a 3 actually I
put 3 there and a 6 there I'm gonna have
to change it as I go that's gonna be a 9
that's gonna be a 10 or - 23 24 and 12
and what I've done for you there if you
double check all the numbers in the top
row will add up to 42 if you go through
and check those the second row will add
up to 42 and all the columns up to 42
the diagonals are 42 the opposite I mean
all four in the corners up to 42 each
four in the corner adds it's a magic
square I love magic squares methods love
these a lot and so there that that for
you Brady that is there as a gift magic
square based on the number 42 now make
one for 50 okay that's another one for
58 this one's gonna be wildly different
at 58 so I'm gonna put a 5 there I'm
gonna put a fool there and put a 3
they're gonna put a 6 there and I put a
1 there 8 and then that one's 38 and
then 39 and then 40 and there you are an
incredible amount of mental arithmetic
later I have managed to you look
unimpressed I'm going to be honest so
maybe maybe all I'm doing is if you gave
me the number n then I'm going through
and I'm doing these are all exactly the
same every single time and so I fill in
those and these are easy remember these
are the multiples of 9 54:36 1872
remember I put nine down there 10 11 12
and then I do n minus 21 I do N minus 20
I do n minus 19 and I do n minus 18 and
that is a magic square the problem of
course and the reason it gets a bit
suspicious with big numbers is you can
look at this one here and you go wait
they're all quite smaller then what's
this there's only some massive 30s and
40s going on maybe a little bit
unimpressed so even though you gave me
58 out of nowhere you look at this and
be a little bit suspicious
so ages are often good because they tend
to be in around the 30s and 40s is
perfect anything too big starts to go
right there are small what if they
because what if you'd like eight
actually it that's why I said between 21
so ages are very good because then this
point if someone says 21 you have a zero
there which I'm kind of okay with I
don't mind zeros it goes zero one two
three anything this morning you get
negative numbers so the square still
works if you gave me a tiny number so if
you gave me something like um eight then
I would have in that spot there I'd have
to subtract 21 off eight and I'll have a
negative 13 hanging out in there maybe
giving me you have you have massive
massive numbers all that diagonal they
add up all this little square in here
they all add up to the same number which
is one seven six
if I now turn it upside down Magic
hexagon if it exists has to be of size
three I don't want to call it the Parker
Square because it doesn't work properly
every be like oh the that's a classic
Parker Square